donc vous souligner le fait que on passe
il faut passer plus sur une logique
d'analysé des besoins en santé au fond
le code de la sangle que le csp prévoit
que les ars dans les territoires et ce
rôle d'évaluation des besoins en santé
on a beaucoup constaté au cours des
auditions qu'en font les différents
acteurs ne savent pas ou ne comprennent
pas comment s'élabore cette décision en
a besoin de vous éclairer notre
commission denquête parce que c'est pas
public le travail des ars et donc les
différents acteurs soient des acteurs de
santé les élus locaux les élus des
territoires ont du mal à comprendre
l'ingénérie comment se fabrique
justement ce recensement des besoins en
santé et les arbitrages parce que c'est
pas au parlement en tout cas parce que
quand l'on dame arrive vous le savez
c'est un chiffre qui nous arrive
quelques jours avant qu'on délibère et
qui n'est fondée sur aucune analyse
d'objectif en santé publique ou
d'objectifs en santé dans les
territoires ça c'est ma première
question est ma deuxième qui vient juste
l'illustré d'ailleurs c'est yade un
sujet récurrent sur les services
d'urgence et les maternités ont fait un
des maternités on ferme des services
d'urgence on a eu beaucoup le débat avec
agnès buzyn qu'on l'avait présenté sa
loi sur c'est quoi la distance voilà qui
est acceptable d'une du banc et la
réponse n'est jamais apporté selon la
dgs quel est le temps de trajet qui est
acceptable maximale entre le lieu de vie
de quelqu'un et une maternité pour pour
ce qui concerne les femmes et la
naissance ou un service d'urgence est-ce
que vous avez des éléments de réponse à
nous apporter sur ces deux questions
sur la question de l'analyse
territoriales je vais reformuler pour
être sûr de bien comprendre votre
question pour moi il ya deux sujets de
deux destinations différentes il ya un
premier sujet qui est l'analyse du
besoin de santé pour l'organisation
territoriale de l'offre de soins ça
renvoie aux autorisations est
effectivement et donc au schéma régional
en fait d'organisations que les ars
refont régulièrement et ça va être le
cas en 2023 qui doit reposer sur une
analyse territoriales qui rejoint la
question des maternités que vous posez
et ensuite il à l'autre vision qui est
de dire pour l'investissement et c'est
une question qui est différente parce
que pour l'investissement jusqu'à
présent je reviens pas sur la façon dont
travaille elle comme pernod qui je pense
était bien connu au jour d'aujourd'hui
nous sommes en train de travailler au
plus tôt le conseil scientifique du cnjs
travaillent sur ces référentiels qui
vont permettre de procéder est d'aider
les ars a procédé à une analyse
territoriale qui doit sous-tendre le
besoin auquel répond un investissement
pour un établissement sur un territoire
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est en
cours de construction pour
l'investissement exclusivement après
chacun rs travail sur cette analyse des
besoins pour réaliser ces schémas
régionaux d'organisation de santé les
sros et sur cette balade base la
délivrer la gravité seul est-ce que
c'est souhaitable est ce que
enfin je ne me prononcerai pas je ne
sais pas comment concrètement travail
les ars avec les uns avec les autres
dans l'élaboration de ces schémas ce que
je sais c'est qu'on en a nous besoin
après pour qu'elle mette en oeuvre les
autorisations et vous le savez les
prochains schéma c'est en 2023
appliqueront l'ensemble des révisions
des décrets d'autorisation que nous
sommes en train de mettre en place comme
des savez nous en avons donc madame la
saison qu'on a quant à elle très bien
entendu merci de votre réponse est très
claire vous ne vous n'êtes pas en
situation de décrire la façon dont les
ars se travaille concrètement et nous ce
que nous disent les élus c'est qu'ils ne
savent pas non plus c'est ce qui est
tout de même là un problème dont on va
dire le partage de l'évaluation et de la
décision sur la construction après des
choix budgétaires parce qu'on on est
tous d'accord qu'il ya des choix
budgétaires à faire on n'est pas en
train de
de dire qu'il n'y a pas de choix
budgétaires à faire mais il ya quand
même un peu un problème quand vous êtes
directrice la dg os ou non vous n'êtes
pas en situation de nous décrire le mode
de travail des ars et nous les élus ce
qu'il me faut remonter c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas en situation non plus de
l'écrire que le sros est l'émanation du
du prs n'ont pas forcément non nouvelle
pensée c'est ce qui me rend très parce
qu'il montrait prudente c'est que le
rôle de l'administration centrale c'est
pour nous d'utiliser de construire des
outils juridiques en matière
d'autorisation d'organisation des soins
des outils financiers que les ars puisse
décliné après c'est aux ars de le
décliner et je ne suis pas la mieux
placée pour le dire et pour expliquer
comment ils travaillent enfin je pense
que ce sera mieux de le poser ou à la
voilà alors après moi je pense que mon
rôle c'est de donner la boîte à outils
[Musique]